hello and welcome to this video against
the Yardbird I've got 56 games played
against him it must it he really must be
my most frequent opponent I think it's
very very likely so what do we get
it's got a wide range of openings that
he plays whose ambit no I don't think so
it's usually going with b6 or yeah
something something like that um yeah
maybe this line yeah that has a distinct
nimzo-indian flavor but why it doesn't
have to play d4 in all cases here for
example you also can play differently
yeah what no I can also I can just take
if I won't show a b3 is also maybe go b3
preparing to take on g5 in a situation
where he has to take with the upon so
that I have d4 next so am i doing that I
think I am it shouldn't be bad really
quince it to or where Quincy to is a bit
it's a bit wrong on the C file as rook
c8 move the certainly going to happen
but I don't really see where else okay
so I'm taking this and then go group d1
I wonder which look look
yeah if the F Rock then f2 can become
can become somewhat vulnerable wonder
what is thinking about Knight a5 or
something like that don't believe this
so okay not really sure what rope to
[ __ ] yeah I'm doing and taking this one
that's the more cautious move but hard
to tell there as usually place the most
aggressive move possible even though
quite often it's not objectively working
yeah I'm not sure at all so of course I
cannot just take the pawn but if I take
once and don't Queen b1 how is he
covering this Queen f6 maybe Bishop d3
is also clearly a candidate yeah let's
do this
yeah I have to admit them sometimes a
bit sick of that I mean II you just
place this is super aggressive stuff
that very often simply does not work
like this yeah this is not not ever
going to work in a yeah if you analyze
it properly or so but okay blitz can
play all kinds of unsound stuff so let's
see how to do that even f4 is an idea F
for Queen moves rook f3 well okay let's
try that it's good rook takes III though
this could be an issue
I was thinking Luke f3 next but he can't
check no it depends on what his moves as
actually yeah here we have three rook
III is probably going to work I can also
just drop back Bishop before the should
before D takes is three rook F 394 this
is this kind of stuff it might work you
can also just go back here for tempo
maybe that one but I can take you three
for e - well maybe but Bishop I can take
two pieces so I can take c8 and b7
it also v4 here
just fall
look every rookie 3 esto so annoying
otherwise Ruka 3 would be really strong
okay hard to figure out maybe is going
97 now but
I'm going to keep the e-file closed here
not allowing him to take
might have 9595 mmm 493 I'm not quite
clear what my mouth is against that
it's a huge 495 and I'm probably too
special see one it's not doing doing
much anyway anymore so yeah it's got
rooked it - bishop form it's going to
take the one but i'm not quite sure i
think it just should still work
I don't don't really see anything great
Bishop a6 maybe it's the usual kind of
yeah
fishing for counterplay stuff that we
have bishop a6 look more dangerous time
warning just you three maybe
ice queen I don't see how he activates
the Queen like that okay check check
check check check
yeah I have shrank
I have some play against the king not
just a draw or something with my pawn
seeum black fortunately I think that's
also a win for white with them with the
check that that is coming with the pawns
him his pawns are not going anywhere
that's always tough yeah and I have
winning positions against him very very
often but lose them because he gets some
some counter play whatever and it gets
gets tricky and he finds some some kind
of swindle or whatever and yeah this is
one of those cases this is just a pawn
or basically nothing if white plays it
right but it's it's difficult to do
difficult to do
I've got a got a question here from a
kibbutz and about the final position yes
so f4 is I guess right and now we should
be at five it's also given by the
computer here and now comp wants to take
on c5 yeah yeah those kind of moves now
it's difficult to play and one point is
that here the queen is attacking this so
boutique's
queen e3 is a pretty pretty clear fair
92 in b5 Jeff it's easy to believe that
the compass right with his plus two but
it's also easy to believe that you can
screw it up okay I went afore that was
not the best mathematically but it
should keep something yeah the engine
now wants to do this and cocci g8 and
gives white just a slight advantage yeah
the thing is that is Bishop one b7 is
very strong and this is what also course
that that nervous innocent it's just wow
I'm just carry yeah that move also is
scary but Bishop c1 seems to be very
good for right now
it stinks we should be for yeah seems to
keep an advantage yeah I was here I was
more afraid of Bishop e6 somehow and
then I have to go here I didn't see
anything
for him but it looked this this is
looking somewhat shaky okay look c3 is
in this is good and whites to keeps an
advantage
tricky business so this happened three
three two and now Quincy five can be
played yeah okay I wanted to play it
safe here and this yeah it's always like
plus one so I'm happy that I didn't
screw it up entirely check yes I was
just happy to get the Queen's off and
here man I don't know I think the way it
went
I was I was winning at the end but he
certainly doesn't have a losing position
right here I think why it's better but
it shouldn't be shouldn't be decisive
maybe I can go up and push push pawns
and it's an attack on the King even
though we had in the rook endgame you
should draw somehow but it's still
something that I'd rather play white
wyden okay thanks for watching